good morning guys so we woke up we
crushed the workout
huh
show me the magic
oh no that could disappear
so yeah we crushed the workout and now
we're trying another one of david's food
recommendations and this one is called
yogurt story and it looks freaking bomb
so he was telling me about these ube
pancakes look at that
and then this k-town chicken waffle look
at this mama
this ube pancake you see that
and then they got
they also got uh aloha french toast i
just saw
there it is look at that
look at that it's delicious
what are you gonna get mister
chocolate waffle yeah
we have a lot of really cool look at
these waffles
ube waffles yeah they have red velvet
waffle they have honey graham waffle
toasted marshmallows and chocolate
syrups s'mores we'll have to get the
s'mores one channel
chili sauce chocolate mousse
cream puff and macadamia nuts or they
have a wet hollywood which is oreo
cookies chocolate with whipped cream
waffle which is pecan crunch brule
banana and whipped cream choco waffles i
also heard they have a loco moco with
prime rib
isn't that crazy let me see
you look confused
you look confused mama what's up with
the face
i'm just trying to figure it all out
right now this is a lot going on is that
really what's going on this guy he
almost fell before like he turned on the
camera like i'm just trying to read the
menu he's trying to take it away from me
papa
look
what just
all right look at that look at that
mouth look at that mouth
even though i have a giant sweet tooth
i'm the most excited for this i've never
had like a gourmet
loco mocha before they asked me how i
wanted it
like medium rare i was like yes please
look at that
okay it's medium but still it's a prime
rib
loco moco
so i gotta get a little bit of this
right
a little bit of this oh i got it you
know i gotta
pop the yolk i'm saying
a little bit of that
he loves marshmallows
i like how he chose the thing that
required zero carbohydrate effort
marshmallow out of the bag chocolate
tell that to the marshmallow maker tell
that to the marshmallow maker yeah try
some of these guys
oh my god i just love how
how like
i was about to say a bad word but how
like
cheesy yeah just over it is
it's like that
try it i like that dude i usually don't
even like mixing my food i like the
sweet after but with that kind of
reaction it's so perfect
it's so perfect
it's perfectly fluffy
perfect amount of coconut milk i was
actually shy away from coconut but just
enough coconut oil
what
yeah how do you like your chocolate
pancakes
is it good
oh my god
my story gives me a mild heart attack
every hour every hour every hour
so i got so
excited about the food i completely
forgot to tell you guys which gym we
went to we checked out a brand new gym
in hawaii called yukio you got to go
check it out if you're into powerlifting
we got
was that mister
you got some of the most legit equipment
out there eleco
competition racks
competition plates really cool
environment the community is cool so
make sure you go check that out that's
yukio
what's up pizza rice one down u k i y o
and the owner is jared super nice
oh
as the dad joke goes
i hated it
yeah it looks like you hated it too
no he didn't yeah he did look you
finished the whole thing
[Music]
your mafia dude
look at that whoa we finished the whole
thing by himself
ew don't say that
that's not funny are they talking about
a picture
yeah
okay
not a picture from this morning oh his
crooked line yeah yeah
look at how he put on his pants the
middle seam is on to the side
[Applause]
you see this beautiful jungle habitat
that we're in look at that lush green
so we're about to go on a really cool
hike but when there's a ton of green and
it's really lush
it is a breeding ground for all kinds of
bugs so one thing i really recommend is
getting one of these guys mosquito and
bug repellent it repels mosquitoes and
gnats and chiggers
and
biting flies and ticks i don't know why
but the word sugars always makes me
laugh
and then also um what's that what's in
that
a gnat that is like a black fly that'll
bite you oh yeah fart papa got those
all the time when we lived in the
mountains
i always got bit by nats all the time
and then also
you got to have some
sunblock because
the sun right now it's overcast is real
nice but it can in hawaii the weather
changes
real fast real crazy like the clouds can
part and the sun will be super harsh so
make sure you stay protected so we got
both of these things on the little duty
my hooties
yeah what's gonna happen on mosquito
bites to you
all right let's go
what's his favorite song right now okay
monkey we're about to go through the
jungle are you ready
you found a jungle bird look at his head
wow look at all this
okay let's go whoa you okay
well you went too fast huh
look i see a stream down there
you see the water down there
what is that
it's called the anchor mister
yeah that's what your mom is to me
i hold you in place like i love it
steady
hold me down i'm like and i'm trying to
drift away i'm trying to drift away just
knocks me down i know i keep i keep it i
keep it feeling like home i like that i
appreciate that baby thank you
what happened mister
let's go down to the stream
do you want to get down there
okay
oh cool oh he went away oh there he is
oh no he's gone
he's still there
whoa
okay let's go
so we're hiking to waimea falls
it's a pretty big attraction here
because as you can see it's ton
of greenery and it's super lush and it's
cool because like every single plant
will have a name tag on it
like that one's called the anderson
bubble that one's called purple mia sp
was that a bug in front of your face
so this is the reason why you want to
have
the mosquito repellent because it's full
of life
like we saw we just saw gekko right now
there's bugs everywhere but it's also
super green hey monkey you want to go in
here look at that oh that's the jungle
and that's also a
strabalanthus esophagus hey what are you
kidding me
dude i got that on camera they're gonna
arrest you
they're going to take you to hawaii jail
you know what they do there
they can do pineapples all day yup
they're not doing hula dances
so you better not do that they're going
to take you to hawaii you're going to be
big trouble you don't want to do that
again you're going to take it to the big
waves you see the big waves i'm going to
throw you in there yep
you better not do that
okay then you gotta be good okay
okay
[Music]
follow mama what did you find mama
[Applause]
what is that
okay let's see don't climb in it okay
let's see what it is
this is
a holla
hale aina
woman's eating house designated eating
house for women and boys that have not
yet been admitted into the hale muah
men were known to have done the cooking
yet only certain foods could be eaten by
women
i love it that's what i'm talking about
why
doing it right what why because why is
it right tell me oh because we gave
birth to the children and we're raising
them and the guys go and they make the
food do all the work huh is that what
that is nine months is not doing work no
i mean guys do all the work i guess yeah
nine months is it of creating life is
not work
i mean it's but the life started in my
nut nuts
and it's been in my whole life
not your whole life
my whole life no my whole life were you
a biology major you don't sound like it
whoa look at this deep jungle
look at that
oh you see a stream over there mister
that's beautiful
are you kidding me
you're eating butt look at all these
ants on this flower that's crazy they're
eating it i found one
that's crazy bones this isn't
hey that's a scary one
right here like this one that's the
scariest one i've ever seen
so this is really cool there's all that
foliage over there
you walk over and then here's this
bridge
and there's more foliage over there with
those big old palm things
and in the middle just open air
pretty cool huh
what's also cool is along the whole
trail they have signs to tell you where
the waterfall is so it's this way
i'm cuny
hey monkey you see the
waterfall yeah
yeah let's go over there let's go whoa
look at that over there
and there's all that stream that comes
down
what we're doing
from the bottom you throw a rock in the
water yeah do it no no we can't dude
what if you hit someone in the head i'm
never gonna hit them yeah you are
wow that's why maya falls
look how big it is so many people could
swim in it
that's cool huh
you want to go around yeah
yeah you can go around
okay i'll follow you let's go
let's go duties
you want to jump in
oh what's your idea then
oh okay
true or false doesn't bart walk like
that with a big old butt are you sure
you waddle dude oh it's about to grab
the straight ah so cute
look at that promise i'll walk with that
guys you're just [ __ ] cute
that kid is gonna waste are you gonna
let me go are you gonna let me go duck
crossing
go dudes skinny
so we just finished this cuny little
hike and since we're gonna spend the
rest of our day
on the north shore side we're gonna stop
by food land to pick up some food and
some drinks
and some snacks because we did check out
two places on the way here like as
you're driving up you'll see uh sunset
beach and waimea beach and they both
look
beautiful just like screensaver style
where it's just blue crystal yeah we're
gonna look for seashells too for grandma
yeah but we won
three
wait what we have three three seashells
we're gonna find one more today okay
don't you worry about that yes
the purple is stinky yeah the purple
one's thinking that's what we were
watching at home in the hotel
hey little hand
oh no sweaty people leave it alone
so ryan when you come inside we got this
hot section where you get some bento
boxes so we're grabbing up some spam
with subies
and also grabbing up some bento boxes
look at this one
hot chicken and spam bento or you can
get chicken katsu
all kinds or you can get a whole chicken
that's a chicken right there
what's also cool is you can come to food
land and get fresh made pokey
there's a ton of which one are you gonna
get mama from california
and then the california two of them
yeah and then can i get to california oh
yeah oh well it's creamy looking
choice for me
you said show your hand california right
yes separate yeah
you want me so show you one bowl and
then i'll give you a half of the
california please
how cool is that
chopstick
good
choice what's pretty cool is in the beer
section they have a ton of local brews
too look at this island
what's really cool too is in the beer
section they have a ton of local brews
check it out
we got kilo brewing company
hola brew
honolulu cream ale
look at all that this whole section
that's amazing
this is what we got some
chips
rental box
soda for the young buck but don't tell
anybody this is the eight in less lane
but she was so nice she goes oh yeah
that's true
it's
a donut are you kidding me
is it your lucky day or what
hey he's on vacation that's true
yes please thank you
is this not the most perfect and
beautiful beach
in the world or what
look at that
blue water
red shorts
[Applause]
how does it feel
perfect
look at that look at that beautiful cove
over there
light little waves
oh my goodness
a sailboat in the distance are you
kidding me
more rocks
our cuny little half dome tent
and a lagoon
look at that dude
[Music]
this is gorgeous
amazing
the mobber just
relaxing in the ocean
so what i especially love about those
rocks over there
is that that's where all the wildlife is
so once i get everything settled splash
around with the family
you know i'm gonna put these bad boys on
and i'm gonna go over there and see
what's going on in those rocks
that's why i'm so happy because it's not
only is it a family beach we got sad
beautiful blue ocean and got a little
munchkin right behind me but you also
got a beautiful rock with all kinds of
wildlife what are you looking for monkey
or sand toys
snacks you want some yummy snacks yeah
that we got from foodland yeah okay we
eat some yummy snacks
look at this cuny snack spread he got
spamusubi and the moment he's been
waiting for
coca-cola
thumbs up it's like a coca-cola
commercial got the red shorts on got the
soda got the blue background brought to
you by
coca-cola and foodland
exactly
and then we got
water sprite
got a bento box spam with souby tyka's
favorite dude
cuny
[Applause]
all right here we go again we were so
comfy at the hotel pool someone was
diving and jumping and now it's time to
go in the beach water and we got a ducky
and someone's scared again come on
monkey let's go
tell everyone why you're scared tell the
whole world
you don't want to swim we'll see cut to
five minutes later okay we'll see fine
okay you promise you don't want to swim
at all okay
[Music]
how you feel now monkey are you so
scared
a little bit but you look way more
comfortable than earlier do you want to
show them you could do it for five
seconds oh yeah i could do it show
everyone we could do five seconds okay
ready yep let's go
one
two
three
four four
hey good job
you held about by yourself for five
seconds a little ducky
good job
well i'm proud of you okay
okay fine little baby steps
little baby steps
can you touch the ground no no no no no
we have to walk
oh my god
there you go look
there you go little ducky man
bye buggy
okay i'll show you the cool footage i
find
[Music]
all right so i swam pretty much to the
outer edge of this cove
as you can see that is the edge of the
cove right there i technically swam past
it because that lines up with that edge
of the cove over there
and i'm past the sailboat
and my bear's tent is that green little
tent over there next to the bridge
i don't want to go too far out because
then i'll be straight up in the deep
ocean
um
i am looking around for fish and cool
stuff
but it feels nice to be out here because
there's less people snorkeling and stuff
so it's just me and the wildlife so far
i've been able to see those big old
schools of fish which i think is super
rad those are really beautiful
um no turtles in sight
but the water is very warm and it feels
nice
so papa is back from his little
his little
sure
his little scuba diving adventure
scuba diving
and um when he came back i had taiko
buried up to his like neck
so now it's papa's turn
but that hole looks like it's only gonna
fit taika
and we've all seen papa's
bulky body
but papa's next in line to do it
okay but this [ __ ] water y'all
this [ __ ] water
i can't get out of it it keeps calling
my name
that goes g-o
[Music]
g-o
excuse me
a little mowgli
okay i think it's big enough
for who
well he doesn't have any patience he
wants me to go asap go away
okay
[Music]
that fits your little hootie butt
he can't lay down it's not that the
hole's not big enough oh actually it is
get him get him wait get him for all
those times
we need that yeah you ready yeah give me
berries
why do you have so much fun burying me
[Music]
use your feet
do you want to use your little feet
[Music]
i like his thought process they're just
random zigzags
i'm gonna get out now
i'm just kidding
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh this feels heavy
[Music]
whoa look at
the puppetron's body is huge
oh look at this oh don't step on my toes
[Music]
we've ruined our son's english
he talks about hooties
and duties oh there's a butterfly
taika yeah are you done time to reveal
papa
yeah where is his body where does it go
it's in the clouds no i need it back
how do we get it back
okay ready do magic
oh
you have to do this
you found my shoulder
oh look at the shoulder
on mama
your sad dash is really heavy sure my
turn
come on help
oh man you got my mouth
get out
come on nice squat 500.
let me see let me try probably let's
let's pop a try
[Music]
[Music]
is it my turn you're standing on me how
am i supposed to be what
let's get double buried
i'm gonna do double buried
i'm gonna get paid with oh we're gonna
get buried with papaya
[Music]
no that's his hair dude that's yucky
hair do you want to get buried with me
it's my turn
i'm gonna do it dude
doing it
okay now it's mamaster
[Music]
how does it feel i know you're
claustrophobic i'm trying to think about
it now i'm freaking out okay get out get
out get out get out get out mama
you can't there you go
there you go
do you feel better now feel better yeah
okay
help mama get out
how about get out it's crazy i can feel
my pulse
like oh like
right isn't that crazy
maybe on my feet whoa i can't get up
[Music]
you can't help mama get out can you help
me get out too yeah